my dad's first lesson to me was look
people in the eye mikha
make sure people see you and you see
them
he has been a proud janitor farmworker
shoe shiner homebuilder and small
business owner
he has seen the world from so many
different lenses and has lots of stories
to tell
but there's one i've never been able to
get out of my head
a story when my dad was a young kid
he and my theo mayo
knew exactly when the trucks would come
in
under the freeway just as the sun set
they jumped the fence to get into the
dump
and as they waited for the trucks they'd
make bets on who would find the best
food
an uneaten apple they could clean
a perfect banana sometimes a candy bar
or wrap sandwich
and then they'd grab whatever they could
find
and save the very best to bring home
to their even younger
brothers and sisters
i hate
that story
but i share it
because we can't solve
what we can't see
in 1936
this image of the migrant mother
captured the living conditions in the
west showing lawmakers what people were
going through
after it published the united states
government sent 20 000 pounds of food
and that image solidified support for
the very first safety net programs in
america
yet still today more than 37 million
americans are still living in poverty
one in six kids
as a student of economics and a career
public servant i know we've been at this
for a long time
but it's my work today
that has given me the hope that we can
finally end poverty as we know it and
here's why right now there are 80 public
benefit programs all across the country
intended to provide critical
anti-poverty resources
yet an estimated 60 billion dollars in
benefits go unclaimed every year
60 billion
i believe in large part due to
complicated outdated systems
that weren't designed to see the people
they serve
i want you to imagine for a moment that
you lost your job and you don't know how
you're going to put food on the table
but you hear about this government
program that can help and so you begin
the process of applying
the first thing you realize is you can't
do it on the only online connection you
have
your phone
because the only way to apply online is
through a desktop computer
so you head to the community library you
go through screen after screen answering
close to 200 questions waiting through
confusing instructions
it feels a little bit like a game of
gotcha
except your benefits are at risk
now if you're from a place like my
hometown a small rural farming town
there isn't an easily accessible public
venue with desktop computers so you have
to find a ride to the nearest social
services office maybe 30 miles away
when you get there you have to walk
through metal detectors with two
security guards past a long table of
scattered paper forms into the main
waiting room
it's loud and there's a long line
leading to that service counter
when you get to the front of it
you're met with a thick clouded sheet of
bulletproof glass
separating you
from someone who could finally help
that has been the system in america for
many communities like mine so it's no
wonder that 14 million americans aren't
enrolled in child and food nutrition
programs or that 6 million are missing
health care benefits
technology has changed almost every
aspect of our lives it's made things
faster more efficient automatic
we need to do the same
for people seeking benefits
i work for an organization called code
for america
we deploy human-centered technology the
kind that respects you from the start
meets you where you are provides an easy
positive experience
and our research has shown there are
four factors we need to overcome
first we know that far more people have
access to the internet on their phone
than a desktop computer so applications
should be online and mobile friendly
second lots of people are falling off
because the process is complicated
so applications need to be simple and
easy to use
third we know that people who are
eligible for one program like food
assistance are pretty likely to be
eligible for another like health care
so let's combine processes where we can
and finally we know there are unseen
heroes in government case workers social
workers on the front lines navigating
old systems we can equip them with the
data and tools to streamline their
efforts
here's what california's food assistance
used to look like
183 questions 51 pages of screens
available only by desktop computer
we took that application and redesigned
it
this is git cal fresh a mobile first
application available 24 hours a day in
multiple languages with chat support
california's food assistance application
went from one of the most complex in the
nation
to being recognized as one of the
easiest application experiences of any
state
for 10 years we have been working with
multiple states on projects just like
that
showing the importance and potential of
digital delivery of benefits and that's
when the pandemic hit and these images
in west valley utah san antonio texas
pittsburgh pennsylvania
parking lots filled with families
waiting for food
america could finally see what we had
been seeing for a decade the growing
number of people in poverty and
communities left out as a result of
failing systems
our phones started ringing
from washington to maryland we helped
states distribute 600 million dollars in
benefits to kids in school lunch
programs louisiana shared used our best
practices tools in notification and
notifying people
they proactively sent out more than 40
million texts to residents on how to
access critical services and in
minnesota we developed an all-in-one
application for nine different safety
net benefits
that
can be completed in less than 14 minutes
nearly 200 000 people immediately
applied in the first six months and for
the first time ever minnesota's system
integrated to reach all sovereign tribal
nation members
that's what is possible and this is the
moment to keep going redesigning our
safety net for a new time and a new age
and we can do it all across the country
as governments reset over the next seven
years we will partner to redesign
systems to unlock 30 billion dollars in
benefits for 13 million eligible people
in at least 15 states
we will bring data scientists and
engineers technologists and researchers
together sitting side by side with
government teams
and
our safety net innovation lab will
improve upon and share best practices so
that every government can benefit
because at the heart of our audacious
goal
is to show the world what's possible
when we use the best tools we have today
human-centered technology and government
so that families aren't waiting in
parking lots for resources
or kids
growing up like my dad
aren't searching for food by whatever
means possible
then
then
we will see
the true potential of every kid and
that's the calling of this moment
to redesign our systems
to see
people
all people
thank you